i'm not going to church anymore it's not
the end of the world let's not make a
big deal
oh god oh god okay
this is it's stuck
no we're gonna die we're gonna die
better not if they find us in these
outfits it's gonna be very bad for the
games
claire we're okay
dad
luke
buddy
you okay
that thing almost fell on me i was
sitting there and it came this close to
my head it's all right you're okay
you didn't get hurt well i'm not gonna
wait around here until i do okay wow
that is a doozy
hey are you guys okay yeah we're fine
you we're fine that was really oh wait
hold on
hello mitch are you okay we're okay
we're okay and phil and claire uh i'm on
the other line with them right now one
second
hello
oh shoot we lost phil we love fear we
lost phil
hello great now gloria's gone
gloria's gone too
oh
hey gloria i know me i feel you're alive
yeah of course i'm alive
for now
for months claire has been after me and
dogging me
anchor the cabinet to the wall what if
we have an earthquake we've got kids in
the house blah blah blah
it finally reached the point where i had
no choice but to just roll up my sleeves
and tell her i did it
oh phil
dad get up here on my way seriously i
just fixed that really what's wrong
mom's stuck
you okay in there we're fine the door is
jammed
oh okay uh
well
let's let's try this together okay okay
um i'm gonna push you pull okay on three
one two three
ah
nothing oh dang it okay here's the thing
i wasn't pushing in fact i was pulling a
little it dawned on me that as long as
claire was stuck in the bathroom i'd
have time to anchor the cabinet to the
wall
it's like they say sometimes when god
closes the door
he closes it so hard that your wife
can't get out
so don't panic i'm gonna get you out i'm
just gonna go get some tools get a
crowbar if you have one what is that
supposed to mean like i'm some dandy who
doesn't have a crowbar well you did just
use the word dandy dandy is a term
coined by miners in the 15th century
just get us out of here
dad how long is it going to take to get
her out of there long time
oh honey don't worry mommy is gonna be
out soon don't panic
wait a minute
wait a minute you're not going to that
party young lady no i'm not going to the
party i'm just going downstairs
with your purse
come on just cover for me this one time
and i
i'll drive you wherever you want
i want to go to the museum of tolerance
fine how far is tolerance i can hear the
two of you scheming out there don't you
dare leave this house oh why do you have
to be such a psycho control freak okay
you know what just for that you are
grounded one week oh that's good
parenting okay
two weeks want to double it keep talking
blah blah blah blah blah blah
four weeks four double it again and make
it ten a week oh my god do you not hear
how much you need to study
what are you doing hey buddy oh just
double checking these straps this is an
extra this baby saved your life that's
why this cabinet barely moved it fell
all the way to the couch it almost
killed me no it didn't this cabinet
barely moved that's just perspective
playing tricks on your mind like if i
hold up my thumb it looks bigger than
your head no it doesn't it looks tiny we
have to look at it from over here how
can i look at my head from over there
phil why don't you just
lie down i got to make sure your mom's
still stuck
so she i can get her out
don't fall asleep
sorry that
you filthy sorry that took so long i'm
gonna go ahead and just take off the
doorknob okay okay here we go
oh damn what what happened i uh brought
the wrong screwdriver so i'll be right
back all right but hurry up phil doing
my best claire oh don't talk back dad
she'll just ground you that's 32 weeks
young lady
i was 16 before right
what
[Music]
you